[Music]
this christmas everyone is excited for
santa to arrive everyone but matpat that
is
i'm cranky and overworked he's a
theorist with a bone to pick are we sure
these christmas cookies were locally
sourced but the man on top of his
naughty list is santa himself when was
the last time these elves got a lunch
break do these stairs not have railings
why is no one in this factory wearing
ppe i'm calling osha will one grumpy
theorist be able to stop christmas from
coming or will he learn that santa is
the biggest victim of all
it's a holiday story for the ages a very
film theory christmas rated pg starting
now hello internet welcome to film
theory the show that guarantees you'll
be placed on the nice list if you hit
the subscribe button tracing back to the
4th century the myth of santa claus has
changed a lot with the times over the
centuries santa has undergone the most
dramatic glow up ever starting off as a
kindly 4th century bishop named nicholas
who lived in what's now modern day
turkey and transforming into a jolly
bearded man who wears a red suit lives
in the north pole and stuffs himself
down chimney so he can deliver toys and
eat all your cookies it is quite the
poke evolution anyway from those
beginnings his modern mythos has been
solidified by holiday classics like
miracle on 34th street rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer silent night deadly
night and of course santa claus conquers
the martians
everyone leading us inevitably to the
1994 film the santa claus as well as its
two sequels which aside from making
people misspell claws for the better
part of two decades also acts as the
most in-depth look into the inner
workings of his north pole operation
ever and what these movies reveal is how
shockingly dark it all is i mean the
idea of santa was always pure and simple
and nobody ever really stopped to think
about the labor force of the elves but
here in 2021 we're more aware than ever
as to the plight of employees and their
working conditions the workforce and our
understanding of it has come a long way
since santa was popularized so today i
wanted to put santa under some scrutiny
how are his working conditions up north
do they meet by modern day safety
standards and with people leaving their
jobs on mass this year should the elves
be next is the ultimate supply shortage
gonna be coming from the north pole
itself as santa has job vacancies
resulting after centuries of elf
mistreatment well ladies and gentlemen
get ready this one's a doozy in the
santa claus movies we learn a lot about
the elf work force in the north pole
they're an immortal-ish race of workers
who've been around since before the
commercialization of christmas and
electricity and even toys as we know
them toys have to be delivered i'm not
gonna do it it's not my job i'm just an
elf we here in the santa claus 3 the
escape claws that they're just an army
of toy building yes men working for the
big man santa himself who's in charge
and from there for the rest of the
entire series the elves are literally
always working as soon as one christmas
is over they immediately start prepping
for the next one without even having the
luxury of a coffee break excuse me are
we on a coffee break we don't drink
coffee then i guess the break is over
that is not an okay mentality to have in
the workplace in 1970 the occupational
safety and health administration or osha
was established which is responsible for
ensuring safe and healthy work
environments in the us and they've been
pretty darn successful at that as
they've reduced workplace deaths by 50
since being introduced so what would
osha have to say about the elves insane
work hours nothing actually osha doesn't
regulate workplace breaks that's
actually governed by the fair labor
standards act so what does it say uh
nothing again but nothing in a different
way you see it doesn't require employers
to give breaks to their employees it
does say that any employer making
employees pull more than 40 hours is
required to give them overtime pay
provided they're making less than 47 476
dollars per year but as far as total
working hours and breaks nothing
actually governs that if you're an
employee you're working at will based on
your employer standards unless of course
you belong to a union okay so the long
hours being pulled by the elves doesn't
seem like it's going to cause a big
issue up at the north pole but even
though osha doesn't limit total working
hours it does have safety standards in
place things like needing to provide
basic protections like guard rails and
sprinklers as well as equipment like eye
shields and hard hats and as we hear in
santa claus 3 many of santa's work
spaces are just currently not up to code
this is not up to code this building
he's not wrong there either when taking
a look at the facilities you'll notice
that there aren't any guard rails
installed to keep the elves safe from
oncoming trains various cables hang
around that could easily zap
unsuspecting workers and when fires
break out in the third film there aren't
adequate sprinklers to take care of them
also i should probably mention the
rampaging robot santa now i don't think
it's explicitly called out in the osha
rule book but employers preventing evil
robot uprisings yeah i'd say it's kind
of implied now while i could go on and
list more of the infractions off and the
specific codes that are being broken
none of it matters none of it santa is
free to do whatever misdeeds he wants
for one reason and one reason alone the
fact that his factory is in the north
pole osha's jurisdiction only covers the
50 u.s states and other u.s territories
the north pole meanwhile has no
recognized government it exists in
international waters even though russia
denmark and canada have all tried to
stake a claim for it as a result the
only rules and regulations that it needs
to follow are those coming directly from
the united nations specifically the
united nations convention on the law of
the sea from 1982. based on these laws
of the sea the only way any authority
can come in and mess with santa's
business is if they can prove that santa
is threatening the elves and forcing
them into labor which gotta admit
despite the insane hours and dangerous
work conditions never really seems to be
the case for the elves in the workshop i
mean motivational lines like this all i
want to see is busy busy worker tushies
are probably cause for an hr lawsuit but
it never seems like there's any sort of
forced labor going on up there unless of
course you're talking about santa
himself big twist time friends you see
the only one being forced into labor by
santa's workshop is ironically enough
santa himself in case you've forgotten
the plot of this movie our protagonist
scott kelvin surprises santa one night
causing him to fall off an icy roof and
die when examining the body scott
uncovers a note that tells him to put on
the iconic red coat he does it which
unbeknownst to him locks him in as the
world's new santa so when you put on the
suit he fell subject to the santa claus
here the santa claus a clause as in the
last line of a contract and putting on
the suit and entering the sleigh the
wearer waves any and all rights to any
previous identity real or implied and
fully accepts the duties and
responsibilities of santa claus what
does that mean it means you put on the
suit you're the big guy you read the
card put on the suit that clearly falls
under the santa claus now you're santa
okay now this business card right here
is just outright contract fraud in order
to have a legally binding contract you
need four key components first an offer
and acceptance someone offers to do x in
exchange for y and the other person
agrees second you need mutual assent
basically just meaning that everyone is
cool with there being a contract in
place third is consent both parties are
signing under their own free will no one
signing while feeling threatened or
being misled and lastly mutual contract
consideration consideration just refers
to the exchange of something of value
from one party in return for the promise
or service provided by the other and the
santa claus spelled with an e breaks
pretty much each and every one of these
things first there is no ascent to there
being a contract in fact scott has no
idea there's a contract on this thing
the fact that it's designed to look like
a business card and that you need a
super magnifying glass to read the claws
makes it almost immediately fraudulent
from there he's clearly not giving his
consent for the better part of the first
hour of the movie he is constantly
denying the fact that he's santa claus
and lastly there's no exchange of
consideration he puts on the suit to
become santa and what he basically
becomes an indentured servant for his
entire life he gets nothing in return
there is only take take take by the
elves in the north pole so not only is
he tricked into signing his life away he
must then endure these massive unwanted
changes to his body as he transforms
into the quote-unquote ideal version of
santa claus that is not okay there is no
consent here also his heart apparently
beats upwards of 140 times per minute as
it plays jingle bells on repeat
what's even weirder is that jingle bells
was written in the 1850s which makes me
wonder what songs the early santas had
playing in their chests i'm assuming it
was gregorian chance but perhaps worst
of all is that he's now alienated from
human society he is deemed unfit to
continue as a part of his family and he
has to leave everyone he loves in order
to work 24 7 up at the north pole put
yourself in the place of scott's ex-wife
who is justifiably concerned that her
former husband has gained a hundred
pounds overnight has grown a beard and
is pretending to be saint nick i mean
that is justifiable cause for concern
and as such she works to suspend his
visitation rights to their son and then
the elves encourage him to basically
kidnap his son please can i go bernard
it's okay with me bernard despite
undergoing the santa training process
with multiple other santas in the past
continues to egg scott on and assist in
taking his kid away from his mother and
step dad for a full month without their
consent if i were to guess bernard did
this because he knew that it would cause
scott's life to be in a shambles from
this point forward he is now wanted for
kidnapping and as such will have to
remain at the north pole in order to
work as bernard says earlier in the film
you leave tomorrow morning you have 11
months to get your affairs in order and
you're due back here thanksgiving and
when scott doesn't do that bernard
swoops in to close it out for him and
wouldn't you know the police do send out
dozens of cops to hunt scott down which
leads to scott being imprisoned sure
there's a special forces branch of elves
that helps to free scott but this only
makes things worse because now it means
that scott is an escapee from jail which
you know is gonna remain on his record
and the contracts only get worse from
there in the sequels if you thought that
the first contract was fraudulent wait
until you see the mrs clause which
requires pretty much an electron
microscope to read cardholder
acknowledges a woman of his choosing i
gotta get married yeah when scott agreed
to this it was totally a consensual
contract between all parties involved in
the santa claus 2 we learned that
there's apparently a mrs claus with an e
which forces scott to find a wife in 28
days otherwise christmas is just gone
and forgotten so scott has to revert
back to tim allen form and tricks a
headstrong middle school principal named
carol to become his wife the proposal
scene here just hurts so much because
carol is forced to say yes in front of
an army of elves who know that she has
to say yes or risk the end to christmas
and if all this 40-day fiancee-esque
behavior wasn't cancelled worthy enough
santa then goes and does the exact same
thing that happened to him he drags her
away from her home and essentially makes
her break off all contact with her
family because the secret of christmas
needs to be kept and i'm sure you have a
perfectly good reason for shutting us
out of your life which as we see in part
three causes carol to go figure become
horrifically depressed so we've got both
our mr and mrs claus both entrapped to
fill their christmas time roles but to
add insult to injury in true capitalist
dystopia form santa is an employee who
just doesn't matter santa is expendable
normally in most santa claus films like
the christmas chronicles or elf santa's
this immortal deity who runs the north
pole however in the santa claus movies
he's a figurehead who can and has died
repeatedly only to be unceremoniously
swapped out in the third film we learned
that there have been at least 50 santas
before scott santa dying is not an
infrequent occurrence in this universe
and you'd think that the death of santa
would be a big deal for the elves but no
when scott kills off the prior iteration
of santa at the top of the very first
movie no one bats an eye none of the
elves say hi to him or ask what happened
to the other santa in fact the elves
actively sass him pointy
and if anything they look annoyed that
they have to deal with a newbie on the
job in short santa is a figurehead at
the mercy of the elves caught up in a
system where he has no control and all
of this is without even mentioning the
mysterious disappearances of the former
mrs clauses the mrs claus is a thing
that all santas are bound by after all
the prior santa had to have a family too
so what happened to the former mrs claus
when santa died hmm suspicious much
never always said that the only way a
toy workshop in the north pole could get
in trouble is if it was forcing people
to work against their will well it's not
the elves that need the help it's santa
santa is a prisoner in his own workshop
the elves entrap scott into an illegal
and fraudulent contract scott's body is
abused against his will any good will
that scott once had with society and his
family is systematically ruined by the
elves he's forced into marriage as a
part of his job and all of it for no
compensation and while the movie's tried
to play this off as a positive thing
like oh look at scott discovering the
magic christmas it's not as even in the
third movie after scott has been a santa
for quite some time he still regrets all
of it are there times when you wonder if
this was even
worth it more than you know wish i'd
never put that red coat on i wish i
never become sam in this world it's not
santa that's the evil employer it's the
elves they're the ones that need to get
those osha violations so someone called
the un we need to defend some workers
rights up north this year don't leave
cookies out on the plate for santa claus
leave the phone number to a helpline but
hey that's just a theory a film theory
and merry christmas give the gift that
keeps on giving this holiday season a
subscription to the channel it's free
and you'll get the gift of a new
mind-blowing film theory episode under
your subscription box each and every
week get put on the nice list this year
with a click of that red subscribe
button
[Music]
you